(energetic music)
- Well, welcome back to another
episode of the "Addy Hour."
It's hard for me to believe
this is actually episode 31.
So we've had a lot of great conversations
over this last year and a half,
so many different guests from
so many different walks of life.
And it's been great to see
how you all have engaged
in these conversations as well,
from things that people have been saying
on social media, from emails.
We're gonna have more opportunities
for some of that engagement coming up,
so definitely stay tuned and stay informed
because we look forward
to having those engagements with you.
So today I'm very honored
to, I was saying beforehand,
this is a day one thought
partner in a lot of ways,
who's joining the podcast today,
just with some of the initial events
that we did around town hall conversations
on different college campuses,
and so I'm grateful to be
able to welcome today's expert
to be able to join us.
And today we have Dr. Myra
Mathis joining us for the topic
of conversation is going
to be addressing addiction
and thinking about faith, psychiatry
and neuroscience perspectives.
So, Myra, thank you so much
for being here on the "Addy Hour."
You have ownership of this, if you want.
I feel like you have
invested into this podcast,
even if you didn't know it from early on.
So appreciate you being here.
- Well, thank you so much for having me.
It's so wonderful to be here,
and to see where the podcast has come
from those initial conversations,
as you were planning and preparing.
Episode 31, that's just phenomenal.
- Thanks so much, I
definitely appreciate that.
And I know some of our
listeners are already familiar
with you because you served as a moderator
for our New York event, God,
Mental Health and Wellness.
We also co-hosted the Grand Rounds at Yale
where we had Lecrae come and
speak to our community here.
But of course this
audience has grown as well.
And there are many who
aren't familiar with you.
So I'm gonna go ahead and
give you a brief introduction
to introduce you to them.
So Dr. Myra Mathis is a faculty member
at the University of
Rochester Medical Center.
She actually trained in general adult,
and addiction psychiatry here at Yale.
She currently provides substance use
and mental health services
at Strong Recovery,
which is an outpatient
dual diagnosis clinic.
Dr. Mathis also serves as co-chair
for the Opioid Response Network,
Black Communities Work Group,
where she helps promote
effective utilization
and dissemination
of culturally responsive
technical assistance
for Black communities
disproportionately affected
by the overdose crisis.
As a clinical educator,
Dr. Mathis also facilitates
educational experiences
for medical students, for residents
and for fellows in addiction psychiatry.
And she pursues her academic interest
in advancing health
equity and racial justice
through scholarship and the development
of collaborative community partnerships.
So someone, as you can hear,
who's deeply invested in education,
deeply invested in the clinic,
and deeply invested in the community,
and so we're honored to have
Dr. Mathis here with us today.
- Thanks so much for that introduction.
- [Nii] Of course.
- It's great to be here.
- Well, I'm excited to
be able to jump straight
into the conversation.
I'm gonna try and hold back
and not reminisce too
much on some of the events
that we've put together in the past,
because there's always just
been a generous response
from people who have been
engaged in those conversations
and who've been appreciative for the ways
that you've helped shape some
of those conversations as well.
But as I mentioned to you,
and as my listeners know,
we always start out just
doing a general check-in.
So obviously there's a lot that continues
to happen in our country
and just wanted to start
and have you share with our listeners
how you're doing at this point in time,
especially with all the
roles that you have.
- Well, thank you so
much for the question.
Yeah, it's a heavy time in our country,
in various parts of the country,
really over all over the world.
There are so many challenging,
tragic, horrific incidences
of mass violence and it's
just a really heavy time.
And now that I'm based
in Rochester, New York,
it's upstate just 60
minutes away from Buffalo.
So those things are still
present with me as it is
with so many of us and
trying to figure out
how to not just be overwhelmed
by the grief and the trauma,
but to be engaged in some form of action
to try and shift that so that
it doesn't feel as hopeless,
and so that we don't feel as powerless.
So that's where I'm at.
- Well, I definitely appreciate
that level of honesty.
And, you know, as we've been talking
to just that tension of trying
to navigate as a society too,
so that we're not just
overwhelmed all the time.
But again, you know,
of course we don't want
to ignore what's happening,
but we don't want to
be stuck in it as well.
So appreciate you just highlighting
that and letting us know
how you're navigating that as well.
As a follow up and I
guess somewhat related to,
what does your day to day cadence
look like in your position
for those who might not be as familiar
with what an addiction
psychiatrist does, for instance,
especially with everything else
that's going on already too?
- So it really varies from day to day,
but I'll give sort of
the mix of activities.
So I'm seeing patients
and I can see patients
who have a primary substance use disorder.
So some days I'm getting
folks inducted on medications
to treat their opioid use disorder
or to help with cravings for
cocaine use or nicotine use,
things like that.
And I may go from that
appointment to seeing someone
who has both a combination
of substance use
and mental health concerns
and talking to them about
medications to address one
or both of those things.
I'm also working with residents
who may be in the clinic rotating,
and they may see a patient.
And then we discuss the case,
and I give them some teaching points.
Some days I'm doing a lecture.
Some days I am in administrative meetings,
actually that's probably every day
that I'm in some sort of
administrative meeting,
both related to clinical work,
but also related to some
of the health equity work.
That's really a passion for me,
and at the core of a lot of what I do.
So the day varies, but
thinking about the patient
and the systems that are
treating our patients,
that's sort of at the core what I do.
- Well, I appreciate you
sharing that as well.
And I think that gives
people, you know, a snapshot
in a sense of some of those things.
I think there's a lot of things there
that we can unpack as well in terms of
how people enter into
the spaces where you are
and how you're also entering
in and trying to meet them
where they are.
But before we go there,
I was wondering if you'd
actually just take people
through your path as well.
How did you get to this place
of going into addiction psychiatry?
Is it something that you
had an interest in early on?
Is it something
that came up a little
bit later down the road?
Like what did that path look like for you?
- Yeah, so it's really interesting.
Actually, it wasn't something
that I thought I would
do from the beginning.
And even my journey to psychiatry
was somewhat circuitous.
When I went to medical school,
I didn't think that I'd
become a psychiatrist,
but my rotation in third year
on the psychiatry clerkship
really opened my eyes
to the difference that could be made,
and also just the importance
from a faith perspective,
what's considered the
ministry of presence,
what it means to actually
just sit with people
and be present with them when
they're facing challenges.
And psychiatry creates an
opportunity to sit with folks
when they're facing various
kinds of difficulties
and to work collaboratively with them on
how to move forward
and take the next step.
So that's how I got hooked in psychiatry.
And then a similar thing
happened to me in residency
while I was going
through various rotations
and I did my addiction
psychiatry rotation,
and I realized that we can actually help,
that treatments work for addiction
and that there is
something that can be done.
And when I'm meeting with someone again,
feeling overwhelmed by the symptoms
of their substance use disorder,
overwhelmed by the consequences
of their substance use,
that we can work
collaboratively to figure out
what that next step will be for them.
And seeing that there was
something that could be done
and that there was hope
within the field of addiction,
that really hooked me.
And that's how I
continued on this journey.
- Wow, that's really powerful
and inspiring just to hear
about what pulled you in.
And I sense that that
continues to motivate you
as you go forward too.
But then even as you just
talked about, you know,
the ministry of presence and all of that,
I mean, it's really powerful.
And I can imagine that people are grateful
for that approach as well.
You know, as you were talking
about just the treatments
that are there and that
these things actually work,
I'm also curious if people
come into your office
or into treatment with that mindset,
or if that's something
that you feel like you have
to instill, or if it's a mixture.
And we'll get into, you
know, some of the stigmas
and things like that as well.
But as you were talking,
that was just one question
that came to mind.
- Yeah, it is a mixture
and it all depends on
where someone is in
their recovery journey.
So I have patients who are
coming in for the first time
and don't really know what to expect,
and, you know, we let them
know what the options are
and let them know what the
evidence shows in terms
of some of the treatments
that we have to offer
and how effective they are and you know,
what they can expect out of the process.
And then I have other patients
who have been in various
treatment programs,
whether it's inpatient or outpatient,
and they've done it so many times
and they just feel like
I've tried everything
and I'm not sure where to go from here.
And that's a tough spot to be in.
But I think it's also
important as a clinician
to hold that space of hope even
when the patient is feeling
like they're in a place
that's hopeless.
And so I'll sit with them
and in a similar way,
I'll say, well, let's
go through the options
because there may be a
combination of things
that you haven't quite tried yet,
or you're in a different
place in your life
than you were in, in the past.
And so something might work
now that didn't work before.
So it really exists along the spectrum.
Some folks are well aware of the options,
and feel like, you know, I'm not sure
what can really happen here.
And other folks are coming
in sort of brand new,
trying to figure out how this
journey will look for them.
So just meeting people where
they are and trying to maintain
that space of hope while they have options
to pursue their next steps.
- That's great.
I mean, I appreciate hearing
that you're meeting people
where they are,
and it sounds like you're
also having a dialogue.
So it's not you just
disseminating information saying,
this is what has to
happen, but really hearing,
as you said, meeting them where they are
and hearing what they're bringing
into the conversation as well.
I think that's helpful on lot of fronts.
- Absolutely, there's
no way that it can only
be a one-sided conversation.
I mean, if you just think
about any doctor's appointment
that you attend.
If the doctor is the only
person doing the talking,
they may suggest things
that actually just don't fit
and work for your lifestyle.
The best medical advice
that I've gotten myself is
when my doctor is actually listening to me
and hearing what my life is like,
and then adjusting the
treatment recommendations based
on things that might actually work for me.
And I feel like that's the only way
that we can really be successful
in any medical treatment,
but especially in the
space of mental health
and substance use.
- Yeah, that's so important.
It actually reminds me of,
you know, some of the comments
that came up in the town hall
that we had in New York City.
I remember Vicky Sigworth
from the National
Alliance on Mental Illness
in New Haven, just
talking about, you know,
and this was much broader
than addiction psychiatry,
but then when people are going in
to see anyone around mental health,
whether the practitioners are
just telling them information
or saying, tell me your story.
It sounds like you're in that same mindset
of what is your story,
what have you been through,
what have you walked through?
Where are you right now?
What have you tried?
What have you not tried?
And trying to find that balance
to have that two-way conversation,
which I think is so
important on so many fronts.
And then even as we think, you know,
even outside or not outside,
but in addition to the
psychiatry, you know,
as I think about as a neuroscientist,
I've had some of those
same experiences as well,
even if I'm talking about, for instance,
in Neuroscience of Addiction,
an event that I did at public library.
That was really a two-way conversation.
It wasn't just me there
disseminating all the information,
but it was helpful to hear from people
what their experiences were
to see how that impacted
how they interpreted what I was saying.
And to also have them share,
well, I was on this medication,
it made me feel this way,
what you're saying about
what happens in the brain is also helpful.
So just kind of a back and forth dialogue,
where we're both able to
learn from each other.
And I think everyone came away from that
with a much better understanding,
even though it wasn't a
clinical setting per se,
but I feel like that's just important
for us to do as a society,
so that we can have better
understanding from both sides,
all sides and really have
a way to move forward.
So it's really encouraging to hear.
- I love that you did that
when it came to neuroscience,
like that's really exciting
because so often conversations related
to whether it's mental
health or substance use,
even the neuroscience of it
stays in a clinical space.
There isn't a lot of
engagement in public spaces
with the science of addiction
or the science of mental health concerns.
And so that's really impactful.
And it sounds like it was also
empowering for individuals
who were there to have the
science sort of presented
to them in a way that's like digestible
and that they can really
appreciate and understand.
- Yeah, definitely.
And it was a really important
reminder for me as well.
I mean, I think there were perspectives
that were changed from people who came in
and also for me as well.
Some people came in saying,
I don't see the addiction
as an illness because
I did this to myself.
- Yeah.
- Which I always say, of course,
that's true at some level
because you have to use
beforehand initially,
if something is going to
transition to that point.
But I think at the same time,
they also came away saying,
okay, now I have a better understanding
of what my use has done or is doing
to my brain in terms of long term.
And I also have a better understanding
that that's not the end of the story,
that there different ways that
yes, the brain has changed
because of the exposure and use,
but it can still continue to change.
Our brain changes for all sorts of reasons
and experiences that we go through.
And there are ways it
can continue to change
and they can move through it.
So I think for me, it was helpful to see
how they also processed the information,
and then incorporate it
into their understanding.
And then I would say for me,
bringing that back into the lab setting,
even for us who are in the lab,
I think it also gives people perspective.
Like why we do what we
do, what impact it has,
and not just thinking about
within the specific lab
environment as well.
So, I think all the way around
those things are so important
from a teaching perspective.
And obviously we're trying to make sure
that we don't keep these
conversations stuck
in certain silos, in certain venues.
In a lot of ways, that's
why I'm so grateful
for the way that your work touches all
of these different components.
Even as you talked about in the beginning,
the administrative roles,
the teaching roles,
the work in the clinic, you're
doing a lot in the community,
I think that's so
important and so powerful.
- Thank you, I appreciate that.
- It's important and hopefully
that feels gratifying.
'Cause I know that when we're
in the work in the moment,
it doesn't always feel that
way, at least maybe more so
for you in the clinic, but.
- You know, that's really interesting.
So hearing you talk about
how you can bring those experiences
with the community back to
the lab, that's really moving
for me because I do think
about, as you said, these silos
and that research can feel
so disconnected from sort
of like the day to day sort of realities,
whether it's of someone's
life and their addiction,
and even the challenges between
what happens in a research world
and what's happening
in a clinical setting.
And that the communication across all
of those settings is
really, really important
to keep patient experiences at the center,
that our research is
informed by those experiences
so that it can help us
do better clinical work.
It's like we need the research to inform
what we're doing in the clinic,
so we can be more effective.
But again, if we're not
really listening in terms
of what the patient experience is,
we may be focusing on a really interesting
and novel sort of research finding,
but how do we bring
that back to the person
who's like struggling and still trying
to figure out their path
and their way forward.
So that really excites me to
see that those conversations
and that engagement is happening
across various sectors.
I am reminded in that same way,
even in sort of my day to day work,
it's not something that
I think about explicitly,
but in this conversation it's reminding me
that often the challenges that I'm trying
to work out in an
administrative setting have
to do with barriers that
I've seen my patients face.
Like that I'm realizing this
is a wall we keep running into.
And so how can we adjust our systems
and our practices,
so that my patients aren't
always running into this wall.
- Yeah, that's such an
important perspective.
I imagine you might
have to remind yourself
of that a few times as
you go through just yeah,
'cause it's easy, so easy
to lose sight of that.
I think as much as we can remember
that across the board in different things
that we're doing is important.
And I would say, you know,
in some ways it's still surprising to me
and I guess it shouldn't be,
but sometimes it surprises me,
the impact that things can have.
So I definitely agree as we need
to move things on a system level,
but even individually sometimes.
So I remember one talk I did
when I was just talking about,
again, the basic science in the lab,
and talking about some
experiments that we're trying
to, you know, do in rats or mice to try
and model addiction or depression,
which obviously you
can't do all that easily.
But trying to think about this
back and forth translation.
And having feedback from people who said,
as you described what was
happening in a clinical situation,
how you tried to model that,
and how you tried to go back and forth,
they said even that gave them insight into
what they had seen their
loved ones navigate
with substance use disorders.
- Wow.
- To me, that was surprising
because I don't often think
about it in that sense.
Even though we're trying to model,
I don't think about what
are people actually going
to get from thinking about
what we're saying about
what happens in the brain and
how an animal might behave
that might give them
insight and understanding
to how their loved one might
be acting in a certain way.
So that to me was really powerful.
And I don't think that's
a common experience
that we think about if we're
talking about the science,
that it can actually
have a direct application
to how somebody thinks about
how someone they know is responding
and how to also approach that person,
having that understanding
about, okay, well this might
be happening.
This set of pathways may be
active in their brain this way.
And that may be causing
them to react in this way.
And maybe I should enter
into that in a different way.
So to me, that was just shocking
because I didn't see it,
even though you would hope
that I would think about that, but.
- But so what you're describing,
and what excites me about that,
and there are lots of folks
in the field of addiction
who have been really trying
to push this message in terms
of the science of addiction,
helping us to combat stigma
because the behaviors
of a person with a substance
use disorder are so hard
to understand, right?
So you're just like,
you're talking about you're
discussing this moment
with a family member who
started to have an understanding
why their loved one might
respond in a certain way.
And that in and of itself,
because the behaviors
are hard to understand,
then they are stigmatized.
And it's like, the science
of addiction can help us understand like
what is actually driving
some of those behaviors
that other people find hard to understand.
When we don't understand something,
we make it an other in
whatever way that is.
It's different from us.
It doesn't make sense.
And so we distance ourselves from it.
But bringing that understanding
in a very practical way,
I think it really does help
us to combat the stigma
and helps us to help families
and individuals understand
why certain changes are happening
in the way someone engages
with their world.
- Yeah, that's really encouraging.
Now it's my turn 'cause I'm gonna have
to remind myself of that too.
You know, just in the day to day
'cause it's so easy to lose sight of that.
To follow up on that, I
mean, since you brought up,
I mean appropriately this aspect of stigma
and how the science can inform that,
how do you approach
that in your day to day,
even though, you know,
there's a range of things
that encompass your day to day,
but how have you tried to navigate
and help people move past the stigma
so they can get to the
place where they are coming
to get the treatments that you
have mentioned are effective?
- Yeah, it's really interesting.
So I find that stigma, it
acts on so many levels,
especially when it comes to substance use.
There's an internalized stigma
where individuals wonder
whether or not they're worthy
because they've been treated in a way
that makes them feel
as though they're not.
And that can happen at various
stages of someone's recovery.
You know, someone who's been
abstinent from substances
for a period of time,
but they're still working
on rebuilding relationships
that have been broken, and
for them to really know
that they're worthy of
healthy relationships,
to overcome an internalized stigma about
what kind of life they
are worthy of having.
And again, it happens along
the spectrum of recovery.
Where I find stigma to be
most challenging though is
in the systems that are
meant to serve our patients.
- Wow.
- And that is the part that
could be really discouraging.
it's definitely discouraging
for patients when they try
to access help.
And then when they finally
sort of make that decision
and have the courage to make
a choice towards treatment
and they're met by stigmatizing behaviors
and language from care providers.
That's the thing that really
makes my job more difficult.
And so I'm very careful in my language.
I model language, even
in the health record,
as I talk about patients and
as I describe their behaviors.
I use person-first language.
I prefer terms like
abstinence rather than sort
of clean or dirty, right?
So these are some of the practical things
that I implement in my daily
work to combat that stigma.
And that I'm humanizing someone
when I'm talking about them,
even in my clinical
documentation that I want
to make sure we see this
individual as a whole person
and not only as someone with an addiction.
So that's where I find myself.
That's the space I find myself
in most often, modeling it,
trying to do some education
with my colleagues
and peers and coworkers.
Some of the clinical research
on stigma demonstrates
that using stigmatizing
language directly correlates
to choosing more punitive
sort of responses to patients.
So it informs the way we decide
to treat someone if we
use stigmatizing language.
And if we read stigmatizing
language in the chart,
it informs how we view that person
and what we think they're
worthy of in terms
of their treatment.
So it really is important
how we talk about addiction,
how we talk amongst ourselves
as clinical providers
and then what that looks
like in a patient-facing way.
- Yeah, wow, that's huge and so important.
Where do you think, and
this might be speculative,
where do you think that
comes from in terms
of within those settings, the fact that
that stigmatizing language is still there?
And maybe another question on top of that,
do you think it's intentional
or is it something
that's not even realized,
just the way that things have been done?
- That's interesting.
So this would be speculative,
but my thought is that we
have systems and structures
that actually stigmatize our patients,
that some of the stigma is
written into policies in terms
of the ways that we treat individuals
with substance use disorder,
the history of equating substance use
with criminality in such a deep, deep way,
and that those policies,
and that those media
portrayals going back decades,
really inform how people
think about someone
with an addiction.
And they see them as sort of
in the worst case scenarios
as sort of a crazed criminal.
And those public sort of media portrayals,
whether you're in a
clinical setting or not,
that's just in the water in society.
And it takes change in
multiple levels and sectors
to really shift how we
are perceiving patients
and individuals with a
substance use disorder
in society overall,
and then also what that looks
like in medical settings.
They're thought of as the
sort of difficult patient.
And because it may take more time
to understand their
behavior, right, then again,
even in a medical
setting, walls are put up
to say that's the challenging patient,
that's the difficult patient.
And conscious or unconscious,
we have these responses.
- Yeah, and then, like you mentioned,
it has an impact on how
things are perceived
when it's written into the chart.
And then to add on top of that,
when you think about our
Black and brown communities,
that's a whole nother level.
So I mean, what have you seen around
that either from your observations
or, I mean, from what's been
sort of researched as well?
Like how do those do two
things intersect in terms
of the language that's used
and people's background?
- Yeah, that's a great question.
So Black patients,
regardless of their
diagnosis are more likely
to be labeled aggressive,
right, in medical documentation.
And so when you add in the components
of substance use disorder, right,
if someone is withdrawing
from a substance, right,
and that impacts their behavior.
They're physically
uncomfortable to the point
that they feel like, you
know, for some substances,
the withdrawal feels like you're dying.
Like you're in such discomfort
that it is overwhelming, right?
And so if a Black male comes
into a medical setting in
that level of discomfort and he's yelling,
and saying, I need help right now, right,
it doesn't engender these
sort of caregiving responses
from the clinical staff, right?
And we know how implicit bias works.
Another aspect of this is
how burnt out individuals
in the healthcare system are,
which means they're more likely
to respond based on bias.
So in the middle of an overdose crisis,
that's disproportionately
affecting Black communities
and communities of color,
right, we need caregiving spaces
to be welcoming and affirming and safe
for people to engage truly so
that we can be saving lives.
But Black individuals coming
into seeking care are less
likely to receive medications
for opioid use disorder, even
in emergency room settings,
which is a critical point of intervention
when we're thinking about
the overdose crisis.
So the data is showing
that the clinical behavior
towards communities
of color is different when it
comes to addiction treatment.
And I think it's the
interplay of stigma, racism,
and racial bias.
Those things in combination
with one another really contribute
to the difference in care that
is offered or not offered.
- Yeah, I mean, even as I'm
listening to you talking,
I'm just thinking about all the impacts
that has on the outcomes.
When I'm thinking, I mean,
it's giving me a level
of empathy on both sides,
both for the person
who is walking through that,
if they feel like they're dying,
then also for those who
may not be responding
to that in the appropriate
manner because of biases
or because of being burnt out.
And again, I'm thinking about
the neuroscience of that.
And if both situations, both
individuals are at a high level
of stress, how that
just can amplify things,
but then it has such
tremendous impacts on outcomes.
And I'm even thinking, as
you talked about in terms
of overdose, I mean, that's a life
or death, ultimately,
situation, potentially.
So again, I mean, just
everything you brought up is
just giving me time to
pause and just realize
how important all these
different components are
at all these different levels.
And as you mentioned before,
it's something that has
to happen on a systems level as well.
So lots to do, but again,
I'm grateful for the ways
that you're doing that.
In some ways, I think
even this conversation
we're having is giving us some insights
about different areas where
many of us can maybe intervene
and be proactive
and make sure that we have
a better understanding
of those types of things as well.
But again, it makes me just grateful
for the work that you do and
for the fact that you continue
to do it as well.
'Cause I think it's a mixture.
There's a lot of hope there,
but it can also be easy
to have some aspect of despair
or is this actually making a bigger impact
and a bigger difference,
which I imagine can
come into play as well.
- I appreciate that.
I was just gonna say when it
comes to maintaining hope,
that also comes with my
interactions with my patients.
That's how I maintain hope,
when we have a moment
and we're recognizing
that things are working,
and we get to celebrate that together.
Like that is just powerful.
I had one of those moments this week
and I want to share.
And I'm just thinking about
the best way to do that.
And so, but this is a particular patient
that has alcohol use disorder
and really, really struggling
with alcohol use disorder,
severe withdrawal,
severe medical complications
of alcohol use,
including pancreatitis
requiring stays in the ICU
for the withdrawal, just
really, really very, very sick.
And we had tried various medications
to help in maintaining abstinence,
but that wasn't really working.
And so we started just talking
through a plan of, well,
what does it look like to
cut down on your alcohol use,
on your own with all of the engagement
and various treatment
resources, coming to groups,
doing a little bit of AA, just
multiple different supports.
And for the first time the patient came
into my office after
not having had alcohol
for a couple of days
and there were no physical
signs of withdrawal,
like blood pressure was normal.
And all of this came from sort
of really harm reduction principles
and slowly thinking about
how this person wanted
to decrease their alcohol use
because medications just
hadn't been working.
And it was the first time
that their body like actually
was showing a physical response
that the plan was working.
So I was just like, look,
this is it in black and white.
We're making progress.
This is good.
So made my week.
It made my week.
- That's great.
I mean, definitely the hope there,
but definitely I'm sensing the joy too
that comes from seeing that shift.
- Yes.
- And celebrating it.
- And celebrating, you have to.
And there are some who might
look at that from the outside
and they're thinking well,
but the person's not fully
abstinent from alcohol, right?
And so what does that mean?
And here I am saying,
no, we take every win,
and we celebrate every win.
And that is worth celebrating.
- Yeah, fully agree.
I appreciate you sharing that as well.
Again, that joy just is so
evident in a lot of ways.
- Yeah, and that's what sustains me,
those moments where I can celebrate
with my patient in the
progress that they're making.
- Yeah, well, that's so impactful,
and so many aspects of you,
you know, being a conduit
to give hope in a lot of ways.
And, you know, just to kind
of wrap in the faith component
as well, knowing that
you're a person of faith,
you know, as we talk
about this topic of hope,
how does all of that intersect
with all, maybe not all,
maybe that's too many,
but many of these things?
It does intersect with all,
but I don't know if you have
time to go into all of that,
but with many of the topics
that we've been talking about,
and then in just your
perspective in your day to day?
- Yeah, you know, it does come back
to that idea of the ministry of presence.
I think that being present with someone,
you can't undersell
the importance of that,
and like to really,
really sit with someone
and to let them know
that they've been heard.
And the medical system can
keep you busy seeing patients
at a really rapid pace.
And, you know, I do my best to minimize
that in my schedule as much as I can.
And I'm grateful to work in a
space that allows me a measure
of flexibility to be able to do that.
'Cause I recognize that that
doesn't happen everywhere
and the need is so great
that there are so many people
that need to be seen,
and it can leave you just
running from one room
to the next, to the next, to the next.
So I do my best to do a little bit
of a self check-in before I
go in a room with the patient
to be sure that I can
actually be present with them
and not just kind of go
through a symptom checklist,
but to really, really
actually be able to hear them.
And I know that that really does come from
what I've experienced in my walk with God.
The importance of knowing
that He never leaves
and never forsakes you like
that He is present with you.
I know how radically that
transforms my daily outlook
to know that He is with me.
And I just feel that there is a way,
and certainly I'm not talking about God
in my clinical encounters,
unless a patient brings that up
to me that that's an important
part of their recovery.
And for many patients, it is.
For some patients, it's not at all.
I have a patient who happened
to find me on Twitter
and told me how he realized
that I was a spiritual person
and he's not really,
and we had, you know, a quick
little discussion about that.
- [Nii] It's a good, honest conversation.
- But just as an example
of the ways in which,
you know, I'm mindful of those boundaries.
And at the same time, I do
feel that it is an extension
of God's grace to be
present with someone else,
and to just sit and hear,
and to hear without judgment
and to let someone know that
they've been understood.
And I'm not able to do that
every day and every visit
'cause it's busy and it's hard,
but I try to take a moment to be mindful.
If I'm having a stressful
day and I know it's gonna
be a little harder than
usual to just be present
with someone then I'm taking
a few moments before I walk in
that room, I am breathing,
I am centering myself.
I'm doing something so that I can offer
that person the best, not
only of my clinical knowledge,
but the best of a human
connection that I can offer.
And so much of the destruction
of substance use is the isolation
and the absence of connection.
- [Nii] Wow.
- So I'm hoping that in a treatment space,
they can at least feel
that there's a connection.
- Yeah, that's so insightful
on so many levels,
just the way that you're
able to step into that space.
And it sounds like a giving back
because you know what you've been given
as you talked about from
that spiritual connection
and knowing God's presence with you
and how much more you can be a conduit
to try and be that for others.
I'm just imagining that
those that you work
with can definitely sense
that in your presence as well
and how far that can go,
especially with all the challenges
that you just mentioned too.
I mean, just to have a space
where people can be willing
to, as we talked about, share
their story without fear
of judgment and know that
someone's there walking through
that story with them,
even though you might not be in it per se,
but that you're there with them,
and how impactful that must
be in people's lives so wow.
Definitely appreciate
the way you shared that.
And I anticipate that I
would think that people
who are listening can
sense that in you as well.
And also give them just
strength and courage
to try and do that for
others, as hard as it can be.
But even the way that you
framed that I think is very real
and very honest.
And you also gave yourself
grace in that too,
'cause it's not gonna
happen perfectly each time,
but as much as you're
striving through that.
And I would add that God is
helping you do that as well.
I think is huge.
Wow, such an inspiration in so many ways
so, wow, I definitely appreciate just all
that you continue to do.
And then your perspectives,
I feel like there's more to come,
even as I know you continue
to step into new roles
and to have different levels of impact.
For me, hearing that,
that's very exciting
just knowing your heart
and the ways that you're touching lives
and investing in lives.
I can only imagine that
those things will continue
to move things forward
for us as a society,
even as it has ripple effects
where you are in your clinical setting,
but how that can also
impact other places as well,
and also what you do on a national level
with different organizations so.
- Thank you very much.
- [Nii] You're in the right place.
- Oh, thank you.
That is very kind and very
much appreciated, yeah.
- Of course, well, thank
you so much for joining.
I hope that our listeners
have sensed everything
that I've sensed as well, just
in terms of your investment,
your wisdom, your excellence.
And I think just the field
and your community is just fortunate
to have you in this role.
And we're fortunate to be able
to benefit from that today
on the "Addy Hour."
And I can't help it, but
the "Addy Hour" listeners,
you've benefited from Dr. Mathis in ways
that you don't even know as
she has invested in this work
and helped to set the foundation.
So this has really been just
an encouraging conversation.
It's always good to talk with you
and to hear what you're up to,
what God is doing in
your life, and the ways
that you're just having
impact across the board.
So thank you so much for joining us.
- Thank you so much for having me.
It's really been a pleasure.
It's nice to have a moment
to like remember the joy,
instead of just running
from one to the other.
It's nice to just have a
moment to remember the joy.
So thank you for that today.
- Of course, of course.
(energetic music)